it is a time of solemn sacrifice in a
country that suffered eight years of
continuous war food supplies in Syria's
adlib province are precious meat from
these animals will be shared among the
community despite the lack of sheep the
ongoing conflicts and the continual
bombardment we don't want to forget our
religious commitments since the collapse
of a short-lived ceasefire last week The
Killing has continued activists say
rockets and barrel bombs have targeted
villages in northern hammer and southern
in Lib the Syrian government backed by
its ally Russia is advancing on the last
part of the country in rebel control
it's an all too familiar scene rescuers
trying to reach the site of a recent
bombardment and another victim since
April more than 800 civilians have been
killed including hundreds of children
400,000 people are homeless Russia and
Turkey the countries that brokered last
week's failed ceasefire are unable to
restore it a few hours north of Eid lib
in the Turkish city of Gaziantep the Eid
holiday is being celebrated with ease
and abundance the city has welcomed
500,000 Syrians it hasn't always been
easy for Turks and new arrivals to live
side-by-side but unlike other Turkish
cities Gaziantep was quick to realize
that many Syrians are here to stay and
has done an awful lot to integrate them
for many Syrians especially the young
this is the only home they've ever known
but even here in the safety of Turkey
the Syrian conflict casts a long shadow
M South NASA fled Syria four years ago
with her son after her husband was
captured by ISIL
there's a sadness in me when I remember
the past the old days with my husband
Assyrians we just simply don't have
Eid anymore you won't be able to
celebrate it until
that has fallen turkey offers hope an
opportunity for her son but ñ saff still
moves among her memories turkey will
never truly be her home and while the
war rages on
neither - will Syria Nev Barca al
Jazeera Gaziantep